Today, I'm gonna show you how to fold a shirt in under two seconds.
Start by taking a short-sleeved shirt and lying it out on its back.
Then we need to draw an imaginary line...
...halfway between the top and the bottom of the shirt, roughly here...
...and another one a halfway between the centre line of the shirt...
...and the outside edge, about here.
We'll call the point where the lines cross A, the top point B, and the bottom point C.
Start by pinching the shirt at point A with your left hand,...
...pick up point B with your right hand,...
...then cross your right hand over to pick up point C.
Next, quickly unfold your arms and finally, use the table to fold the shirt back on itself.
This method works with any short-sleeved top, from T-shirts, polo tops and shirts...
...and with a bit of practice can be done very quickly.